اذا كما اشار امين وشيماء المباحثات لم
تتركز فقط على حرب اوكرانيا انما ستتركز
ايضا على التبادل التجاري وكذلك السياسه
الدوليه فيما يلي عرض لابرز التعاملات
التجاريه تحديدا بين البلدين في يناير
الليله من العام الجاري احتلت روسيا
المركز الاول
كمصدر للغاز الطبيعي الى الصين بحجم
مليارين و700 مليون متر مكعب كذلك ارتفع
حجم تبادل التجاري بنسبه
116% عام 2022 حاليا وصل حجم التبادل
التجاري الى 186 مليار دولار ومن المرتقب
ان يصل الى 200 مليار دولار بنهايه العام
الجاري العسكري فتعتبر الصين من ابرز
مستوردين اسلحه الروسيه خاصه منظومات
الدفاع الجوي اس 400 والمنظومه الصاروخيه
والمقاتلات بالتوازي تتطلع روسيا للح صول
على تكنولوجيا الطائرات المسيره الصينيه
وتكفيف التعاون في هذا الجانب اما في قطاع
السيارات فاقد حلت شركات السيارات الصينيه
محل الشركات الغربيه واليابانيه والكوريه
في تصنيع السيارات داخل روسيا